you probably can't go anywhere in the
world where they're not gonna know your
face anyway they're not gonna know oh my
god even if they don't speak English
because the show has been dubbed into
every single language it's shown in
every corner of the world have you had
that experience where everybody there
anywhere you go people know who you are
yeah and you're right
no in the face is the kind of key point
they know the face they don't
necessarily know the name and they don't
even necessarily know the name of the
character sometimes because the
characters are dubbed into different
write names
so once I was in London with my
girlfriend and these two ladies came
over they were from Spain very charming
and they said oh we love the show we
love Game of Thrones and we love we love
your character and we love Jon Snow and
Jon Snow
Jon Snow is is the character that my
character spends the most time with and
he is you know I'd say how achingly
convincingly attractive yes KITT is a
yeah a very very handsome fella yeah and
you know we love we love you we love Jon
Snow you know we were kind of in love
with Jon Snow so what yeah alright and
they said and they said can we have a
photo and I said yeah absolutely and
then we took a photograph and then they
said goodbye and they said their names I
said I'm Maria and I'm Elena and I went
oh thank you very much I'm Jon and they
went oh we wish
[Laughter]
I'm sorry but you wish you are